Sorry, I'll go tomorrow.
Sorry, I'll go tomorrow. Thank you. Yes, I'm on the 1st floor. I
recently moved to
Achinami. My name is Dou.
Can I ask your name? I
'm Ito. I understand that you're Mr. Ito. I look forward to working with you
in the future.  Please, please,
by the way, I'm teaching English, so if you have a lot of
interests, I
understand. If there's something else, I
'll be there in the 10th session.
Oh, it's been a long time since I've been to a hot spring. It
feels so
good.  Do you like hot springs? I like hot springs. It's
the best when you want to relax. I
come here often too. Yes, I live right next door. I'm
jealous of you. I
think you're from America. Where do you live? It's
near a supermarket.  Ah, it's on the other side of the station. Yes, that's
right. I'm familiar with that area. I hear you often go there for drinks. Yes, it's
near the station. It's a
nice place. Yes, if you'd like,
come over to my house after this.
I'll have a beer. I'm going to take a cold bath now.  I'm going there,
so I'll go with you
H.